[Music]
one of the very interesting features of
our capacity for friendship is that
natural selection has also equipped us
with a capacity to break our friendships
so it's not as if once you make a
friendship you keep that friendship for
the rest of your life most of us are
familiar with the idea is that
friendships have some lifespan sometimes
they're lifelong friends but on average
the typical bestfriend lasts for about
10 years or so we've looked at this in
the United States you make friends and
sometimes you break friends it doesn't
need to be a bad breakage it doesn't
need to be a catastrophic one but you
know the friendship is not as intimate
or as close as it was or maybe it
disappears now there's actually quite an
interesting explanation for why we have
this capacity not only to make
friendships but also to let them go
imagine that I forced you to be friends
with someone and to work together to
achieve some objective like a kind of
high school science project five of you
the teacher says okay you five are going
to work together on this project and one
or two of those individuals within the
group are lazy and they're not doing
their part they're not cooperating there
what it's known technically as defectors
or Free Riders now what are your options
your options are to do the work for them
and many of us in high school hated this
type of dilemma or not to do the work
and also defect and maybe get a bad
grade so if you're choosing whether to
cooperate or defect with someone who's
defecting and all you can do is choose
whether to cooperate or defect what you
find is that ultimately most people wind
up defecting so in a rigid social
structure in which people are stuck with
particular other individuals when those
individuals start not doing their part
taking advantage of you if you're stuck
with them then you wind up not doing
your job either and the whole group
collapses and descends into a kind of
you know Anarchy a kind of awfulness in
which everyone is mean to each other but
if you allow people the capacity to
leave the group to say you know I don't
want to hang out with you anymore I
don't want to be connected with you
anymore I don't want to be your friend
anymore because you're taking advantage
of me that capacity actually supports
cooperation within a group if you allow
people to switch friendships it makes it
easier to sustain cooperation because
now people have a second way of
communicating their dissatisfaction with
someone who's taking advantage of them
but you don't want too much of that
you don't want too much social fluidity
so the relationship between the ability
of groups to work together or
cooperation on the y-axis and the social
fluidity on the x-axis with total
rigidity being here and total fluidity
being here gives you a parabolic curve
because if you have too much fluidity
you also don't make an investment in
your friendships if every day you have
new friends why would you invest in that
person they're here today they'll be
gone tomorrow
and if you think about it there are many
institutions in our society which have
evolved to put you in that middle range
we have an institution of marriage which
kind of makes it so that you declare
that you are getting married to this
individual if we make divorce impossible
and so you are stuck with your spouse if
your spouse becomes a mean person what's
your only choice you'll become mean too
or you spend your whole life being taken
advantage of so you get both spouses
being mean conversely at the other
extreme if it were trivial to divorce
your spouse so every day you had a new
spouse also you wouldn't be nice to your
spouse why bother they'll be gone the
next day so you want a set of rules that
make divorce difficult but not
impossible you want a set of rules that
have that puts you in the middle range
that optimize your impetus to invest in
your spouse or think about for example
the the home mortgage deduction that we
have we have a set of policies in our
society that try to incentivize people
to stay fixed in a neighborhood but we
don't want them to stay too fixed let's
consider it again if you have an
environment in which nobody can move
like in Stalinist Russia for example or
everyone is assigned an apartment and
you're stuck here and you can never
leave when your neighbors start putting
graffiti or polluting the hallways or or
degrading the Commons why should you go
out and clean the hallway in front of
your apartment if everyone else is
dumping their garbage there so you start
dumping your garbage because you're all
stuck in this place and anyone starting
to defect ruins the Commons conversely
at the other extreme if every day you
had new neighbors why should you go
sweep the sidewalk in front of your
house or trim the hedges between your
house and the neighbor's house if the
next day the person will be gone so you
want a set of policies that stabilizes
neighborhoods
but not too much doesn't make it
impossible for people to move and then
again you get optimal investment in
local communities it's the same with
friendships you want the capacity to
leave your friends precisely so that
they will become your better friends
[Music]